and the cornerstone of such obligations
is indivisible security principle the
heads of states and governments
have
clearly
stated that
not
no participant of the oec
should ensure their security by damaging
the security of others so when jens
stoltenberg
made this highbrow and arrogant
statement that no one can breach the
principle of the washington treaty in
accordance with which those are open for
any candidate wishing to accede to the
nato
we can say that we are not party to this
organization we have not signed this
treaty but we have signed
a broader pan-regional euro-atlantic
document
which includes the principle of
indivisible security and if jens
stottenberg believes that nato members
can ignore this principle that is
enshrined in the documents adopted at
the highest level then perhaps it is
indeed time for him to get a different
job because he does not perform his
functions very well